(audience applauding)
All right, it is time for "Drew's News",
the only news that makes you feel
like you're snuggling 100 puppies.
(Drew imitating animals chewing)
(Drew imitating cat purring)
(Ross laughing)
That's a cat.
All right, and with me at the desk,
is my trusty co-pilot, Rossi Ross Matthews.
(audience cheering)
Hi, everybody!
Hi, birthday girl!
And joining us, well, it's her birthday too.
(audience cheering)
And she's one of the finest
comedic geniuses of our time,
and you know her from the SNL Hall of Fame,
as well as so many other beautiful credits,
Rachel Dratch.
Yeah!
(audience cheering)
Hi!
(Drew chuckling)
(Ross chuckling)
(audience cheering)
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday.
Thank you!
But it'd be great birthday for someone,
for her baby to be born 2/22/22.
So for all the babies popping out today,
congratulations.
Congrats.
You've done a great thing.
And thanks for watching!
(audience cheering)
All right. First up.
(audience applauding)
We all try to keep track
of all the important birthdays in our lives,
but sometimes we mess up,
and one mom in Minnesota bravely admits
that she had the wrong birthday for her three year old son.
I love this story.
(Ross chuckling)
People reports, Emily Vondrachek says
she's only figured it out when her insurance company
had a different date in their records.
Ha-ha.
They flagged it
when she went back to check
her own birth announcement on Facebook,
she stood corrected.
Watch this.
His birthday, is indeed the 25th.
For two years,
I've been celebrating his birthday on the 26th,
and now I have to call my pediatrician back,
and say, "Ha-ha-ha, You know what?
I had my kids' birthday wrong".
You wanna know the worst part?
The worst part, it's my middle child.
(audience cheering)
(Ross laughing)
Hilarious.
(Rachel chuckling)
And why, it's not great, okay?
But I'm not gonna mom shame you.
I'm not gonna do it.
I will, I thought about Angela Jolie.
Didn't she get like tattoos of the longitude latitude,
or the birth dates of all her kids or something?
That's a good idea.
(audience laughing)
Or if you don't wanna do a tattoo,
you could just be like, "Hey Siri", you know,
"remember this day forever".
That'll work too, and I just will say,
parents can do so many different things
to screw up their kids, right?
If this is the worst thing you did to your kid,
your kid's gonna be fine.
(audience cheering)
Don't worry about it.
All right, Ross, your story.
All right, well, next up,
one of the buzziest shows on TV,
everyone's talking about "Euphoria",
(audience cheering)
and it just, yes,
it just got picked up for a season three.
So congrats to them.
It's getting a ton of attention,
not just for the teen drama,
but also for those incredible aesthetics,
the Wall Street Journal reports,
even adults are taking fashion cues
from the teens of "Euphoria".
They're inspired by the bold and sparkly looks
that have earned costume designer, Heidi Bivens,
two Emmy nominations,
and Rachel, we actually took the liberty
of putting you in one of the looks from "Euphoria".
(audience laughing)
There you go.
(Drew laughing)
(audience cheering)
That's what you would look like if you "Euphoria"
I like it.
out yourself.
Stretchy.
Yeah.
I like that.
You do?
Yeah, I don't give that much thought to fashion.
Except for today, I wore flowers for you.
So cute.
But, except for today.
No, often, I leave the house in like, a before picture.
(Ross laughing)
That's my, yeah.
(bright music)